Радіють війні?
Це відео начебто зображує російських солдат, які танцюють перед тим, як відправляться на передову в Україну.
Відео розповсюдили на кількох платформах, його переглянули тисячі разів.
Однак відео зняли не в Україні. Воно датовано 2018 роком.
Насправді там військовий оркестр Узбекистану на концерті в метро.
Через зворотній пошук зображень ми знайшли старіші версії відео та визначили його локацію за допомогою Google Maps.
Ми натрапили на фотографії станції метро в узбецькому Ташкенті, а не в Росії.
Відтоді як Росія напала на Україну, тисячі фото і відео з полю бою заполонили інтернет.
Але будьте вкрай обережні з тим контентом, яким ви ділитеся!
Далеко не все є справжнім - або тим, чим здається.
На цих знімках нібито бачимо, як атакують російські літаки.
Однак насправді це фото з відеогри "Arma 3".
Це далеко не перший випадок, коли публікують фото з ігор, використовуючи їх як зображення справжніх бойових дій.
Подібні фейки були і під час кризи в Афганістані минулого року.
Але наступні зображення не запозичили з ігор.
Тут ми бачимо групу винищувачів, які летять над містом.
Користувач Twitter написав китайською: "Пряма трансляція війни в Україні".
Однак зворотній пошук картинок показав, що це скриншот, датований 2020 роком
і насправді демонструє повітряне шоу в Москві.
А ось що трапилося на відеоканалі німецького видання "Більд".
Там показували картинки з мало не тисячами російських солдатів, які нібито парашутують над Харковом.
Принаймні, так це пояснив ведучий.
Однак ці кадри виявилися старими.
Ми знайшли аналогічне відео у "Фейсбуці", завантажене у 2016. Кадри, як виявляється, з Росії.
Або це відео з TikTok. Воно показує величезний вибух,
нібито внаслідок атаки в Україні за день до початку російського вторгнення.
Однак, що мало б вас насторожити - дерева і кущі на диво зелені для лютого в Україні.
Ми перевірили давніші версії та знайшли кілька зображень однієї події -
все за допомогою зворотного пошуку зображень.
Відео насправді показує заправку в російському місті Новосибірськ, яка спалахнула минулого літа.
Отже, жодного зв’язку з війною в Україні немає.
У зоні бойових дій, подібних нинішній в Україні, ми стикаємося з потоком зображень у мережі.
Деякі з них фальшиві. Тому, перш ніж ділитися таким контентом, варто перевірити двічі.